because i think this is a good
transition to going to disney
uh and i'm sure everybody is following
this story it's all over the place and
it's multi-dimensional but i read the
story here from daily mail uh disney
president who is the mother of
transgender and pansexual child says she
wants at least half of all future
characters to be
lgbtqia i mean i i used to remember
lgbtq now it's like qia or racial
minorities theme parks are now banned
from saying hello boys and girls okay
a disney executive in charge of content
kerry burke vowed to up the ante on
gender politics during that all hands
meeting promising that at least half of
the characters in its productions will
will be part of the lgbt community to go
from racial minorities by the end of the
year that's half 50
right meanwhile business diversity and
inclusion chief vivian ware said that
they no longer address theme park
visitors as ladies and gentlemen boys
and girls instead as dreamers and
friends the comments after
came after governor desantis signed the
don't say gay bill into law
disney partner nadine smith co-founder
of equality florida said the goal of the
republican bill was to make children
from take children from their parents
what are your thoughts on the story with
disney this is a whole can of worms that
we could really get into i mean first
with the whole don't say gay bill
nowhere in the bill is even talking
about saying gay and that you can't say
gay and all these kind of the words not
even in the bill yeah no i mean my bill
is the word i'm saying gay right now i'm
in florida with you guys right now am i
going to be arrested have my my bank
account
can we bring them in please can we bring
that
it will yeah
it's just ridiculous and the whole part
like look at america's demographics i
mean you have like one percent of the
population that's that's gay maybe it's
up to i think three percent now with the
young people which has also gone up in
in recent years it's gone from one to
five percent yeah we talked about this
with gatsat he was surprised that the
number one from one to five in the last
20 years are those numbers again please
one percent
to five percent in the last 20 years as
well people will say that that the
number of people that i identify as the
lgbt it's so high in the younger
generation and that's why this is so
insidious because at least to me it so
much of this is being pushed on children
you go on tick-tock you go on these
places and you see these teachers
talking about transition closets where
their their students can go in and
change their clothes and they don't have
to tell their parents and teachers and
schools are doing it behind parents
backs and
pride flags everywhere i mean
kids don't really know this stuff the
teachers and the the education system
and a lot of the mainstream media as
well is pushing this on children i don't
believe that those numbers are legit the
left will say that oh these these
numbers are because people feel safer
now to speak out about their their
sexuality but to me i just i don't
believe it i think that so much of this
is being pushed on children to influence
them and not all of it is real
i have two points on this and then i
want to get pat's thoughts on because
he's the only one here that has kids so
i want to hear what pat specifically say
on this but pat hit the nail on the head
as he was reading the story he said
you know the
lgbtqia i was like hold on what well
there's more letters now right i
remember when they threw q in there i
was like all right what's what's the
whole cute thing all right that's like
was that whatever that now there's an
eye and i literally have never seen the
in the a in there i've never seen that
i've seen lgbtq and this is going to
sound like i'm a homophobe i'm not i
live in south beach i've partied with
gay guys and lesbians i have friends my
ex-girls best friends was a lesbian
couple like i hang with these people
but you know
kind of like what bill maher said i'll
bring it back when you start to lose
people that are actually on your team
and they start to be like hold on what
that's where you start to lose people i
was an advocate for gay rights sure gays
want to get married they want to be
unhappy like the rest of the people have
at it guys
but now you start to look at just common
sense things here like what is happening
here
now on to the kids
i don't have kids i don't know what it's
like to have to worry about sending your
kids to school
and then being indoctrinated by whoever
whoever teacher teaching them whatever
whatever whatever i don't have these
concerns thankfully so but as a parent i
mean is this something that like keeps
you up at night is it like do you talk
about this in the house how do you
approach it so so let me tell you when i
was 24 years old the guy asked me uh he
says why do you want to be rich you talk
but you want to have money and i said
it's very simple for me like if people
ask like the real reason for me to want
to have money it's very basic one
i wanted to have a house
that had all the toys and had to park in
a backyard where every one of my kids
friends would say let's go to
patrick's house okay that's number one
okay very important maybe because i can
control i'm a middle eastern i'm not
comfortable with sleepovers you want to
do that you do it at our house and we
got a pretty great security system we're
going to do our part right that was one
at 24 25 years old okay now you were
saying when i had my kids absolutely
when i was when i was i said when i have
kids i want them to go to the private
school that i want them to go to none of
it had to do with the lambo ferrari
whatever whatever right i said i want
the kids to go to the private schools i
want to go to i want to control it right
next you know all these things that i
went through service respect i want all
these things okay i don't want to be
judged for being from iran i don't want
to be judged from being armenian
assyrian this is who i am treat me as a
regular guy that got some value did his
part and then let me decide the life i
want to live okay
that's drive i can't even describe to
you for somebody that's born in iran how
much it matters to me for you not force
anything down my throat i can't tell you
the emotion it generates when you try to
force something down my throat i can't
stand it a forced thought a forced law a
forced position i must take with my kids
we're one one time at a mall i don't
know where we're at and i'm talking to
my kids and one lady's like you know you
don't say that to your kids i said i'm
sorry what this is how i raise my kids
i said do you have any kids no i don't
have any kids i said ma'am why don't you
go find a partner and have kids and you
raise your kids and let them be
successful and write some books about it
but till then mind your own business
these are my kids i'm raising right i
was at the whole uh uh uh arts museum
deal you know the art deal i don't know
what the art bazel art thousands are
about whatever you invited me that was
great and i'm there before we go and i
look at dylan i look at you guys so look
at me guys i said your brain's about to
get a workout yeah you're going to go in
here your brain's going to see art some
of this stuff's going to be weird but
it's getting a workout okay this is how
art is it it works out your creative
juices i love that mom and a dad is
looking at me and they're like oh my god
i've never heard anybody tell this to
their kids i don't know if i'm raising
my kids the right way or not i'm going
to find out in 40 years when i'm dying
at 83 years old but it's my job i chose
to have kids with my wife it's our
decision on what we did and my wife and
i dictate how we raise our kids and we
are open to feedback and opinion and
strategies that we may consider to do
that but it's our kids and i got 18
years with these guys okay outside of
that
go be it okay let me do this part and
i'm gonna find out if i did it right or
wrong we could do a lot of things wrong
but
what i can what i what i'm concerned
about is the following here's what i'm
concerned about
go back when you went to school i'm
curious to know what yours was as well
when was the first time in school at
what age did they start talking to you
in colorado about what it meant to be
gay lesbian and transgender how old what
grade was it then let me just say one
thing about what you just said about
about the kids because that is exactly
why republicans want virginia because
you have the exact same mindset that so
many other parents have yeah and it's
because of that of why they want by the
way that's scary for midterms and 2024
for democrats because they're realizing
that's something you don't mess with you
can mess with a lot of people you don't
mess with people's kids you can call me
out i can call you out but if i say
something to your wife or if i say
something to your kid i may get a
different reaction from you right go
ahead it was also the critical race
theory and terry mcauliffe right
virginia just the education system
in general it was basically the phrase
that the soccer mom has now turned into
the coven mom right and basically
you know
the swing voters are talking about the
the the soccer mom the covet mom is the
reason that trump lost and it's also the
reason that terry mcauliffe lost in
virginia right that's the swing vote
but here's my concern though let me tell
you who i'm concerned for let me tell
you what i'm concerned for
i'm concerned for
the mom and dad who make 48 000 a year
okay
that can't afford private school that
can only go public school
and they're in a coding that they can't
go to another public school that feel a
little bit more comfortable about
because the way they zone it with
schools where you can only go there with
zip code they come and investigate your
id all this other stuff
i am so concerned for that family
because that mother is like kids gonna
come to come home from school confused
and what do you do so we are raised to
tell our kids hey you better listen to
your teacher i'm sorry i'm afraid to
tell kids today you better listen to
your teacher no i don't tell them you
don't know what i'm saying the teacher
what the public school system in america
has done has turned children not into
creative passionate thinkers it's turned
them obedient to authority and it
doesn't puts them in a box exactly what
you're saying it doesn't make them into
people who want to discover new ideas or
make something very new it's it's you
have this life you live this life
exactly how you're supposed to and don't
deviate from that and if you do deviate
from that if you're a boy and you chew
your pop tart into the shape of a gun
you know you're you're evil and all
these different types of things how old
what grade were you when the teacher
taught you about gays lesbians and
transgenders not that not brother but
teacher right that was elementary school
what great do you remember fifth grade
what grade was it for you i i can't
remember a teacher teaching me about
that i can't remember that i don't know
that wasn't a thing do you remember that
never never i remember i mean i had a
gay major in in junior year high school
but they never taught us about it i i
had it in high school as well i don't
remember anybody ever teaching me about
no gays lesbians and transgender i
remember there was a kid in seventh
grade
that
you just knew he wasn't like part of the
boys he wasn't on the football team
that's what i'm saying right um
and he was kind of
he was gay turned out to be gay but we
didn't underst we were kids i mean the
meanest kids in the world are eighth
grade kids like like
if i'm thinking of when i was my meanest
self it was eighth grade right and i was
a stand-up comedian could you imagine
i'm looking for laughs everywhere i go
yeah i was not nice to that kid and
years later i saw him i'm like hey man
like we're cool is that but i have a
problem with that as well yeah and i
think in that example uh i think
somebody needs to come in and have the
conversation with the kids
on on that part okay where you know the
bullying part because i i agree i know
looking back at it believe it or not you
listen
if there's anybody that doesn't like a
bully it's you know what i'm going to
say it's different now though yeah this
isn't like a 1980s jock movie you know
where people are good giving gay kids
swirlies and stuff like exactly this
isn't revenge of the nerds right exactly
this is this is 2022 where now no matter
if you have more intersectional
ideas about you you're gay lesbian trans
black whatever it is the better off you
are in those types of situations correct
so it's really in a lot of ways that you
see with young white men are doing worse
academically doing worse socially in all
these places straight men with young
white straight men exactly you know so
now it's like flipped on they over
correct it ain't cool to be young and uh
be a white straight guy anymore no so
the florida's bill is what that you
cannot talk about transgender and gay uh
up until third grade correct
our third grade bring it up in school by
the way when i read that i'm like i'm
sorry
you mean fourth grade it's okay
how old is somebody afford exactly
what do you mean you want to bring it up
in fourth grade
i don't even support fourth grade well
what fourth grade what fifth grade what
the hell like what are you talking about
so when do you support having that no
potential first of all like what's
health and guidance
i remembered we learned health and
guidance from kim sinclair
my teacher her name oh she's my pen pal
we write letters to steal today was this
sex ed i remember taking sex yeah yeah
but by the way she's the reason why i
joined the army shout out to kim
sinclair she was my favorite teacher
she is
a politically on the complete opposite
side that than i am
every guy she dated we'd go out on a
date and she would say do you like this
guy do you approve of him this lady is
older than me but i play a role of an
older brother and i protect her she was
very good to me i joined the army she
had a very positive impact on my life
she literally has there's a letter
sitting on my desk and i responded back
to her on on text uh thanking her for
the letter but i remember saying i'm
like okay i learned about sex cool i
already knew about it but i don't know
you know the whole the banana and the
condom and all the stuff and you're
watching these videos okay cool now
you're in what grade by the way health
and guidance in glendale was at 10th
grade that's what i like at that point
i'm in favor of a 15 16 year old
learning about i think that's the age
what the hell are we talking about even
being okay with fourth grade elementary
school and should not i am so confused
well we're here you've gone through
puberty yeah here's the thing like
go to the conservative folks that are
like wow it shouldn't be dark but
fourteen [ __ ] i'm sorry what i'm
terrible what are you talking about
you this shouldn't even start till high
school that you talk about this should
not even be brought up till high school
is when you start having these types of
conversations do you know how confused
kids will be my kids and i were watching
a movie the other day and in the movie
you see a i don't know what it was a
girl kisses a girl and my five-year-old
daughter sitting there says my wife and
i'm like
daddy is that okay
so then i give my position on it
and then it's like oh okay
all right then i'm like turn this damn
i'm like i can't even watch some of the
movies that i so now disney wants to go
50
they were doing going to the park and
asking people like i'm canceling my
annual membership i'm cancelling this
i'm cancelling that and this is not cool
they shouldn't do this dude they can't
even say boys and girls anymore they
have to call them dreamers and friends
so this if we can't even say hey boys
and girls what are we talking about
how often at any event good evening
ladies and gentlemen i'd like to walk
like all the time that's just normal
right but you see this
why the these people are so mad about
this don't say gay bill and not being
able to teach it to children is because
think about what you just said saying
boys and girls and ladies and gentlemen
not being able to say that or thinking
that leah thomas is a woman any of these
types of things the only people who have
the brain capacity to believe these
types of things are children
because otherwise it just sounds so
ridiculous to just normal people normal
people just hear that and say this is
just crazy so they influence children
yeah they push it on them young so that
when they get older they believe this
all their life and they know that
they're not going to get out of it when
i was in the army we used to go to this
gay bar best club in nashville tennessee
was called connections they shut it down
in o3 let me tell you it was a
ridiculous experience it was the studio
54 of uh uh what do you call it of
nashville like if you've ever seen a
movie studio 54 that's exactly what it
was i mean
i'm not so i'm surprised they took that
long to shut this place down it was
a
guy took me to this place
yeah why are you going to a gateway oh
because
racials are on your side it was all
right actually i totally agree with you
it was just if you're a straight guy
there's always girls there you're going
to you're going to bring up time that we
would go there i have when i left the
last time i went to connections we have
a picture two years ago i have the
picture till today
i have the picture until today and it's
in my uh am i no joke not the picture
till today you should see the picture
everybody hugging me six of them around
me they're all gay
okay and then two of the guys from the
army they're straight and they're like
they're crying we're gonna miss you
greek god you know we're gonna not
gather so everybody had their own name
and all this stuff yeah your little
little joke i would tell them i would
say you know so so what what nationality
what's bad david i'm like i'm a syrian
sicilian
after like 50th time trying to explain
what the hell is this and i said you
know what yes i'm sicilian so since 18
years old yeah i've had a side name of a
of
the greek god vinnie delucci would go
i'm not a joke i'm not even kidding we
got all these things
but here's the point it that didn't
bother me but i was 18 19 20 years old i
knew i i'm comfortable i love women i
like this i'm very comfortable in my own
skin i'm good but to start that at third
fourth fifth grade i don't think you
start to still tenth grade and i think
they're you shouldn't start it at all
and at what point at one point in any
education yeah should you be talking
about home like it kids will figure it
out amongst themselves this is not to be
only one
only one reason look you and i can teach
the concept of stocks five different way
you and i can teach capitalism in five
different ways
you can tell capitals and say yeah
here's capitalism it's the rich taking
advantage of the poor it's kind of like
they have their employees looking at
them as slaves that's your way of
explaining capitalism spot-on he could
say capitalism is the people that
inherited all their wealth from their
family and they had a head start and you
don't so capitalism benefits those with
a head start that's his explanation my
explanation as a teacher of capitalism
maybe listen folks there's many
different political systems in the world
many different economical systems in the
world but the one that gives you the
biggest fighting chance without a
four-year degree without a two-year
degree without an mba without needing a
last name is capitalism it's hard it's a
lot of work it's gonna suck you're gonna
lose a lot but if you work your ass off
you read the right books capitalism's
for you we all explain capitalism yeah
but we explain in a different way the
way you explain
lgbtqiabz whatever the letters are the
way you explain it has to be very matter
of fact
here's what you're going to see this is
what this is here's who that person is
here's your approach when you run into
them bullying is not okay no matter who
the person is you cannot judge people it
goes back to very basic fundamentals of
conservative beliefs this whole concept
of judging people needs to go more where
we teach it meaning we teach it more not
to do it i think that's the approach but
the the other side that's like if you
don't you're this and maybe you have
these thoughts and if you do this is
what to do
oh no no stop right there bro chill out
relax
matter of fact style of teaching no
judgment no bullying this is not
acceptable we move on
not the other in-depth type of a style
teaching i don't know if you understand
what i'm saying that but
it's not it's not a matter of fact
because look at all the people that are
pushing this they're all college
educated i mean this is all coming from
the colleges and universities i mean
it's indoctrination from kindergarten
all the way through your graduating year
of college it's straight indoctrination
so it i don't think it should be
addressed at all because it can't be
matter of fact right that's exactly
right
um
i do think their sex ed is totally
appropriate and 10th grade and and you
know call it nine ten whatever high
school and the middle i'm cool with that
i'm gonna give you one little
perspective here and i don't have kids i
don't have an opportunity to say this
story all that often i'm gonna give you
two stories real quick
i came into your office one time and
this was regarding my sister
and my sister and i kind of got into an
argument with her and i was like you
know what because she's a big theater
broadway whatever
and you know i i'm really tight with my
nephew that's my guy rory love that kid
nine years old he's a boy he's a he's a
boy and she's like you know i'm
enrolling him in ballerina classes and
you know i want him to kind of start
doing what i do i go
i go gent this is not what
i no
i like
she i've just i know what she's used to
and south beach and dancing and broadway
and i'm just like
rory won't play soccer right yeah i like
soccer she's like but he can also learn
i'm like
i put my foot down like i'm like i this
is not happening in my house so just
like you're not the dad i'm like my
masculine tendencies were like this
isn't happening right and i was just
because i was a sports guy i played
football in college like i this is the
closest thing i have to having a kid my
nephew like don't even kid's nine years
old eight years old at the time
flipping on you
the most emotional i've ever gotten i
told him the other day when you were in
the office
i told tigran this the other day he
posted a video together tomorrow uh he
posted a video of daniel like scoring
like three goals this guy's a beast okay
he's like five years old yeah and when i
was in dallas i like that was my homie
that was my guy like i would practice
soccer with this kid
and
i was like not even joking like choking
up watching i'm like look at this guy go
look at him do his thing
five years old and i could just imagine
if a teacher
was trying to indoctrinate
whatever it is to a five-year-old to an
eight-year-old to a nine-year-old my
fatherly instincts are like this ain't
happening bro
so
the the whole don't say gay thing just
like
i think there's anything we're
establishing here what you used with
like the 18 year old i'm sorry when
you're at the the greek god story
dude you're grown up do what the hell
ever you want with your life yeah do not
put your freaking hands on my kids brain
and start indoctrinating to whatever you
think they should be doing hands off the
kids when it figured out as an adult
do whatever you want catherine that's
just said the super chat she says isn't
gage as part of society why does it need
to be taught why are we treating gay
people as different interesting
perspective by the way forward to say
that here's another one this should be
no surprise this is from cove 12k
uh x12 this should be no surprise as
parents have been outsourcing their
responsibilities to schools what a
freaking that one
name to give you
credit
brother you talked about the favor it is
you said the 48 000 household with the
the mom and the wife and you're worried
about them even if you have to send your
kids to public schools there is going to
be time where either the dad or the mom
can sit down and actually have dinner
with their kids which a lot of parents
won't do read to them talk to them about
the issues of the day maybe in the
morning at breakfast whatever it is you
have to find time as a parent to work
around the schedule to undo some of the
things that are happening at the public
school you have to be a responsible
parent not a little point
if you don't do it then then
that's your fault that is your fault
parent if you don't do it you know you
know it's crazy
uh
you know how uh this whole thing with
will smith slapping him got chris hart
not chris hart kevin uh chris rocks we
have a chris hart so chris hart kevin
hart chris rock totally turned off so so
this whole chris rock situation for his
ticket sales to go from what 45 bucks to
phone to 50 bucks yeah okay i think i
saw something going for a thousand
dollars yeah i'm not surprised because
everybody wants to see what he's going
to say because everyone's going there
for his reaction on that that was so uh
and by the way that netflix special
could sell for 60 million bucks so but
uh what's it called
so
it pushed will's reaction originally oh
my gosh chris didn't do anything helped
chris out right in chris wins
i think
if i'm running a church today
if there's ever been
the right messaging to increase
attendance it's today
if there's like if i'm a public school
if i'm a if i'm a parent that 48 000
year parent
and i'm sitting there thinking about how
do i equalize that and match it because
you need to match it right
you need to find a lo like there's never
been more important of a look catholic
lds judaism whatever whatever you
whatever you are
somebody that's teaching conservative
beliefs and conservative is not
christianity just conservative right you
know stealing marriage biblical
principles all this stuff
i think there's never been a more
important time for parents who can't
afford to send kids to private school
but you can afford to send your kids to
a church i think there's never been more
important of a time to take your kids to
church
like you know i gave a talk in newport
beach to a group of pastors who were
talking about how the donation and
tithing has gone down and you know all
this other stuff and i said just look at
what mormonism is doing they're doing a
great job their youtube channel rocks
they're great at getting people and
converting and baptizing until you're
you know everybody leaves for two years
when they go to their uh what do they
call it mission trip that they go on
i said but today
if if there's ever been a time where
attendance can double triple and you can
again start seeing these massive
crusades of churches being packed with
three four five ten thousand people i
think it's today no but you're
but those i don't know exactly who those
pastors were that you talked to in
newport beach but there are a lot of
pastors in california specifically ones
that i work with and i'm getting
requests from all sorts of different
churches that didn't shut down during
covid that stayed open and they have
seen their numbers triple quadruple
five tuple whatever it might be they've
had so many more people come in well a
lot of the the churches that don't
really speak the truth or speak this
feel-good message of christianity
whatever it is they're faltering and
their their numbers should go to where
you go i go to pastor jack hibbs church
he's the one who baptized me about a
year ago this uh calvary chapel chino
hills and riverside yeah that's the one
i go to but also you know rob mccoy's
church out there in woodland hills uh a
lot of great churches that are just
seeing explosions and numbers because
they're actually standing up for truth
do you go to his presence do you ever go
to shepherd of the hills do you go to uh
dudley rutherford do you know i haven't
okay got it no dudley rutherford is in
ranch is in the uh portal ranch okay and
he's got a church 20 000 members
incredible church but yeah yeah i think
attendance got i think as a parent today
if you can't afford to pay fifteen
hundred dollars a month to a private
school you can afford to take your kids
to church every sunday well not just
that if you're listen if you're a parent
and you're gonna vote pay attention to
who you're voting for it's that simple
don't just check a box on a school board
council member they did this in san
francisco they voted out three
incredibly radical school board members
because they were tired of what they
were promoting if you're going to vote
[ __ ] pay attention it's your
responsibility to know who you're going
for
it's a great point but it's not a
realistic point because how many times
you go to a ballot and you check the
ballot box and you vote for the
president the vice president and you
know zero other names and you shouldn't
be on the four pages i agree with you
that you shouldn't be voting yeah well i
a lot of times like circuit county judge
i'll leave it blank if i don't know a
name or have a any affiliation i will
leave it blank but that's just not how
it works bro like people are going to
vote they're going to check a box
they're going to see an r next to a name
they're checking r they're going to see
a d next to a name they're checking d no
matter what the hell else they they know
they're just going r d and if there's no
political affiliation they're just
incumbent
that's also the problem with the voting
system that's the point is that i
consider myself to be
pretty smart not the smartest but
certainly smarter than most and if i can
barely make out what the hell these
voter you know ballots are basically
saying then i don't know what the hell
most of americans are even understanding
they do that on purpose and i think
you're exactly right of what that's
going to happen but
i think that i mean especially the left
the left will push people to vote so
hard even if they're uneducated and i
say don't vote if you're not educated on
what's going on you shouldn't because if
you're going to be an informed voters
actually care about what's going on you
should be informed you've got a pretty
strong uh
belief system on how the voting system
should work i think your belief system
on how to vote should be the same way
companies that ran or and families
around and how our families ran if your
kid doesn't pay rent money you don't
have a voice on what we buy and don't
buy and whatever
if you work for a company and you don't
own a share i'm sorry you don't have a
voice right only shareholders get on a
shareholder call berkshire hathaway has
a meeting with their a shareholders in
omaha nebraska where you hear from him
and charlie monger because you earned
the right to go in there because you own
one of their shares at whatever dollar
amount three hundred thousand dollars
a sure it is i think we're allowing like
think about if if our voting system was
the way families and businesses ran
that's kind of like me living in my
house with my kids and my kid's
six-year-old best friend can come in and
vote for how we should run our household
yeah tell me how that makes any sense
somebody can come and tell berkshire
hathaway how they should run their
company even though they have not
contributed to the organization they
have not contributed to the company's
growth they've not bought a share they
don't risk the risk that berkshire takes
but they want to tell them how to run
things no no your vote doesn't really
matter that much because you're not
contributing to society i think the
system needs to be a way to contribute
to society so you think that certain
people shouldn't have the ability to
vote or certain people should have
more votes than others i think the
messaging needs to flip to be earned the
right to vote i think that's the
messaging you ought to earn the right to
vote then the current system do you see
that changing at all zero no i don't see
that changing out i'm just telling you
well they had that whole right people
have dreams you know i can dream so it's
a very different
people
no they had that that that new voting
thing that said oh republicans want to
take away voting rights from people it's
like no we didn't we wanted to so that
you had to vote on election day so that
you didn't use a mail-in ballot so that
you couldn't be an illegal immigrant to
vote and that you actually had to show
an id apparently that's restricting
people's right to vote all that's doing
is securing the vote and making it so
that people exactly like you're saying
who actually
play some part in society are actually
voting but apparently that's taking away
people's right to vote no i think that
you're right i think it's too easy to
vote for a lot of people yeah
i think like listen you come like i came
to america i'm like i feel like i owe
america something america doesn't owe me
nothing like
america gave me this life so hey i'll
serve the military i owe you i'm in debt
to you america you ain't in debt to me
i'm in debt to you
you you didn't tell me to come here i
chose to come to america 200 other
options and i came to you so i got to
give to you i don't think that messaging
is being given since this one president
that we had that got assassinated years
ago who said don't ask what
your country can do for you instead ask
what you can do for the country when's
the last time we heard that messaging
it's no 5.8 trillion dollar bill let's
let's give more money well why don't we
talk about that and that's perfect with
jfk because jfk was talking a lot about
the federal reserve in his time if you
enjoyed this short clip click over here
to watch another short clip and if you
want to watch the entire episode the
entire podcast click here
[Music]